elle a bossé il ya deux ans en hausse en
basque sans protection donc on peut
prendre deux filles voilà et je ne peut
pas traiter les gens actuellement comme
ça là c'est sale affaire ne l'approuvé
pas de marolles en plus à moi je
voudrais pressé quelque chose d'aussi je
ne suis pas anti vaccins je trouve qu'il
est utile que les personnes avec des
comores pour les gens qui souhaitent
pouvais pas dire non non si je peux le
dire parce que c'est la vérité c'est
bien de chouettes écouter quand même ce
qu'elle est et pourquoi donc non mais si
oui c'est de
les écouter c'est pas possible alors que
vous ne voulez s'est terminée avec vous
lancez message de
masse il est dangereux je ne sais pas
quoi mais on a décidé je voudrais parler
c'est pas vraiment non plus de moi parce
qu'à moi je travaille avec de l'humain
soyez patients qui
le rend on est trois infirmières sur 4 à
partir mais pas son ampleur mais passe
on savait que j'étais pas avec ce nom il
voulait continuer à être soigné par mes
soins que je me teste pas ce que je fais
attention monsieur g contaminé j'aime
moi si on l'actionné vous mais non
rendez leur leur révolution tellement
non c'est trop
pourquoi ne pas autoriser les autotests
pourquoi ne pas autoriser les tests
[Applaudissements]
mes patients
pas suffisant je fais ça et que je suis
dans ma vocation c'est de soigner c'est
pas de dire vacciner pas vexer ma
vocation c'est de m'occuper de gens qui
sont malades vanessa vous avez été
vaccinés contre l'hépatite b quand on
commet si c'est pas le débat
je vous salue et de fouiller non
attendez je paie la paire défense et
derrière vous lui parlez les mac
vous avez été vaccinés contre l'hépatite
b quand en quelle année pendant mes
essais ça me regarde pas ce
dossier médical
j'avais fait consciemment je n'ai
accepté mais si ces missiles alors que
sorte de la vaccination jeudi s'est
passé pas un secret parce que pour tous
est obligatoire pour tous les soignants
sa nomination contre l'hépatite brno ce
n'est pas un secret médical mais la
question que je pose la question que je
pose c'est que moment où elle s'est fait
vacciner contre l'hépatite b on était en
train pleine polémique sur la sclérose
en plaques bon d'accord et donc on a pu
constater que l'ensemble des soignants
et ans vaccinée contre l'hépatite b il
n'y a pas eu davantage de sclérose en
plaques chez les soignants que dans le
reste de la population mais à l'époque
on sait vacciner on sait vacciner en
sachant qu'ils avaient qu'il y avait ce
doute qui était qui était mis sur la
table et de la même façon actuellement
alors que ce vaccin il a été fait quand
même il ya eu 5 milliards de vaccins et
récent moi je demande du temps mais
donnant même il est beaucoup plus chaud
excitant pour moi j'ai envie de rire à
valence avait proposé d'autres non mais
attendez j'ai envie de gerber dire à
vanessa juste de revenir à vanessa parce
qu'elle est pas tout seul
ce genre vais te dire à vanessa c'est
que 1 diana on n'a jamais étudié un
vaccin autant que celui là jamais autant
que celui là s'il est facile a été mis
rapidement sur le marché parce que
c'était un vaccin dont la rn ont leur on
le traitait ont leur on le connaissait
depuis plus de 20 ans 1 et la grâce à
l'argent qui a été mis grâce à l'argent
qui a été mikko l'argent qui a été mis
sur cette recherche toutes les
étudiantes et ce à toutes les phases ont
remis à respecter et le vaccin mis sur
le marché redonner des moins d'un
brillant hôpitaux parce que tout le
monde tous les moyens
je sors ce que j'essaye de dire ce que
je veux dire à vanessa elle me dire que
j'ai eu raison d'avoir peur de ce vaccin
il n'y a pas de raison d'avoir peur et
que et que tu encore ce match les
raisons d'avoir peur du covin au point
où je me fais quelque chose à
contrecoeur non mais c'est pas ça mais
c'est comme vous avez quand vous êtes en
frontal comme vous êtes un homme vous
savez les gens les gens qui se font les
gens qui prennent toutes les précautions
malheureusement on n'en connaît pas mal
qu'ils prennent toutes les précautions
plus vite ils ont chopé ouais d'accord
parce que c'est un truc qui est
extrêmement contagieux et même en
prenant toutes les précautions il ya un
moment on fait les erreurs sur est
pourquoi on prend pas en compte les sans
logis